agotados se empiezan a mostrar los
trabajadores de la salud en francia que
hacen frente al aumento de los casos de
kobe 19 por la variante o micro por ello
las autoridades del país anunciaron
restricciones para los viajeros del
reino unido que registró este jueves 88
mil 376 nuevos contagios dichas medidas
entrarán en vigor a partir del 18 de
diciembre e incluyen entre otras cosas
la presentación de una prueba negativa
menor a 24 horas
sería joven y útil y muy chic
limitaremos los motivos que permiten a
los viajeros entrar desde el reino unido
a francia y todo esto tiene que ver con
el turismo y los viajes de negocios para
las personas que no son ciudadanos
franceses ni europeos las personas que
no son residentes franceses obviamente
estarán limitadas de filósofos y no
haber límite varios son los países que
empiezan a restablecer restricciones
para limitar los contagios y el colapso
de su sistema de salud del presidente de
eeuu chop aires advirtió que se acerca
un invierno mortal para los no vacunados
y urgió a quienes no se han aplicado las
dosis de refuerzo a hacerlo
o micro en este aquí va a extenderse
mucho más rápido a principios del
próximo año y la única protección real
es recibir vacunas
en nueva york las autoridades anunciaron
una serie de medidas
eres twitter that y está claro que la
variante omicron está aquí en la ciudad
de nueva york con toda su fuerza force
se distribuirá en medio millón de
pruebas caseras rápidas de forma
gratuita a través de organizaciones
comunitarias directamente a las bases al
tiempo que asesores externos de los
centros para el control y la prevención
de enfermedades recomendaron priorizar
la vacunación con los fármacos de facer
y moderna por encima de la dosis de
johnson y johnson debido a la poca
efectividad de esta última y el riesgo
de efectos secundarios